[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
derek chauvin chooses not to testify in
his own defense
i will invoke my fifth amendment
privilege today we break down competing
expert testimony about what caused the
death of george floyd
as both sides rest their cases if he
even
hints that there are test results the
jury has not heard about
it's going to be a mistrial and the
family of dante wright speaking out
after the police officer charged with
manslaughter for shooting him to death
is released from jail on bond the
justice would bring our son home to us
knocking on the door with his big smile
plus two suspects in the disappearance
of a california college student decades
ago appear in court why the prosecutors
say
kristen smart was killed during an
attempted rape
we certainly believe that uh mr poor's
dorm room
was a crime scene law and crime daily
covering court cases from
coast to coast
and welcome to long prime daily i'm
brian ross in our studios in new york
with brian buckmeyer on assignment in
minneapolis for the trial of derek
chauvin and our co-host terry austin
both sides have rested in the trial of
the former minneapolis police officer
charged in the death of george floyd
testimony ended
without hearing from the defendant
himself brian buckmeyer is here with
more on that brian
yeah brian ross we saw a conversation
between eric nelson and derek showman
for the very first time
where he was given a mic in the ability
to take off his mask as eric nelson
walked through the fifth amendment that
the right is his and his alone that no
one was threatening him or pressuring
him to testify
or not to testify and for a slight
moment we saw a little bit
of derek chovan's personality when eric
nelson said that they've been going
back and forth for quite some time even
up until wednesday night
and that they finally decided for derek
chova not to testify and you saw a bit
of a smirk
from derek chovin in reference to going
back and forth
so many times here's eric nelson asking
derek shoving those in very
important questions whether you intend
to testify
or whether you intend to invoke your
fifth amendment privilege
uh i will invoke my fifth amendment
privilege today
is this your decision not to testify it
does your honor
all right do you have any questions
about your right to remain silent or to
testify on your own behalf
not at this time i don't right does
anyone uh
promise anything or threaten you in any
way to keep you from testifying
no promises or threats your honor you
feel that your decision not to testify
is a voluntary one on your behalf
yes it is so brian as a public defender
do you think this was the right call by
derek sheldon
i think this is the right call for a
number of reasons first if i'm defending
this case this case is about the burden
of proof
whether or not the prosecution has
proven each and every element beyond a
reasonable doubt
second there are some questions that i
don't think derek chauvin
can answer why did you leave your knee
on george floyd's neck so long
when was the use of force uh
inappropriate and at what time
why were you there and so fearful of the
crowd there are some things i think
it'll be hard for him to answer
but of course the fear also is that
cross-examination
he can what we call open the door by
talking about his peacefulness
his knowledge about medical care
whether it be cpr after the fact or that
someone can die from a
knee to the neck and those answers as to
his peacefulness or truthfulness
can open up for example the tax case
that he's got going on
or other uses of force that are
questionable in his past all right
thanks brian and with that decision the
defense rested
and an argument over testimony from a
prosecution rebuttal witness began
with threats of a mistrial long crimes
anjanet levy is here to tell us all
about that
anjanet brian all of this had to do with
carbon monoxide gas that is an odorless
and colorless gas
that can kill you and the questions were
really about whether or not that was in
george floyd's blood
and contributed to his death
if he even hints that there are test
results that the jury has not heard
about
it's going to be a mistrial a stern
warning from judge cahill to prosecutors
after they announced they planned to
call breathing expert dr martin tobin
back to the stand
to rebut claims from a defense expert
that said carbon monoxide from a police
cruiser exhaust system
could have killed george floyd dr fowler
was pretty clear he was not saying that
this was the cause of death
he's simply opining that it wasn't
considered
by the state and apparently it was
considered to be a ridiculous concept by
the state of minnesota
that didn't they didn't think to test it
dr david fowler told jurors floyd's
carbon monoxide levels should have been
tested
now prosecutors say they have those test
results
it was discovered yesterday by dr baker
special prosecutor jerry blackwell said
baker reached out to them
after hearing fowler's testimony judge
cahill called the late disclosure
prejudicial to the defense
it's just by serendipity that
dr baker calls the state and says
oh by the way it does exist it should be
in there it seems to be very odd i'm not
claiming any bad faith on the state's
part
cahill allowed dr tobin to return to the
stand
to testify about test results the jury
had actually seen
if the hemoglobin is saturated
at 98 it tells you all there was for
everything else is two percent
and so the maximum amount of carbon
carbon monoxide would be two percent
tobin says two percent would be in the
normal range
dr tobin is really considered one of the
state's star medical witnesses he had
previously testified that
pressure on george floyd's neck from
derrick shovin's knee
cut off his airway and therefore cut off
the circulation of oxygen to floyd's
brain
causing his death now the defense expert
meanwhile testified that
then that was dr fowler that the knee
did not cause
floyd's death brian andrette dr tobin
was the last witness the jury heard
before and be sent home
that's just what the prosecutors wanted
right oh i think it's exactly what they
wanted um they were probably just
itching and looking for a reason to put
him back up on the stand
the jurors from all of the reports we
had been given
from inside the courtroom really seemed
engaged he's very charming he has the
accent he's considered
you know the foremost authority on
pulmonology
he's an expert on breathing he wrote
what they called the bible on that
so anytime you can end your case with
somebody like that
it's considered a plus and terry austin
in the battle of the experts we saw on
this trial who do you think came out
on top there is no question that all
the experts as far as the prosecution is
concerned came
out on top we saw that the use of force
expert
for the defense was cross-examined and
he did not hold
up on cross-examination he basically
admitted everything the prosecution
wanted him to
admit and we just saw in the clip with
dr fowler and dr tobin that dr
tobin came out on top with common sense
he said for a fact if the carboxy
hemoglobin
measured you know two percent that means
the fact that
if all of the oxygen is measuring 98 2
is the most it could be it can't be 10
to 18 and that's what fowler said
he also said that fowler mentioned all
the studies that he couldn't find there
are at least 20 studies that
there were for this very issue showing
that
pressure on the back is going to narrow
the
hypopharynx so i think at the end of the
day the prosecution
brought on much better witnesses for
their expertise
for both the cause of death and for both
the use of force
and brian from your experience in court
with all these experts how does the jury
make sense of who they want to believe
so it kind of came up when judge cahill
said to
eric nelson that he was not going to
give a directed verdict that the jury
can credit
one witness over the other even if it's
the same
side so they can look at dr tobin and
say okay
he said something a little bit different
than the other doctors but i'm going to
credit
him the most and therefore i'm going to
reach a conclusion based on his
testimony
they can literally cherry pick which
ones they want to believe
and not believe even if it's only from
one side rather than the other
all right thank you very much still
ahead on law and crime daily
the suspect charged in the disappearance
of a california college student
now under investigation for other
alleged sexual assaults
but first dante wright's family
demanding justice asking how the officer
who shot him
could have mistaken her service pistol
for a taser
[Music]
the police officer charged in the death
of dante wright is no longer in jail
she was released on a 100 thousand
dollar bond angering the family
long crimes ken johnson is here with
more on that kim
hi brian yeah just as the community here
in minneapolis was hoping for some
closure
now that the derrick chauvin trial is
coming to an
end a new case is just beginning kim
potter
the former brooklyn center police
officer who shot and killed donte
wright over the weekend made her first
court appearance
thursday she allegedly mistakenly used
her gun
instead of a taser to subdue wright who
resisted police as they tried to arrest
him during the traffic
stop now wright's family along with
their attorney ben
crump held an emotional press conference
at a nearby church
calling for justice here is a 20 year
old's dad
aubry wright speaking about his son's
death take a listen
my son was very much loved we loved him
a lot
and the way he was killed he did not
deserve that
so i just wanted to say that i felt like
i had to just tell you guys
what's going on is unfair these young
black men being killed
can you blame my son or anyone else from
being scared of the police
we teaching our kids
how to act around police the former
officer has been charged with
second-degree manslaughter a charge not
strict enough according to attorney
crump who compared this shooting to
muhammad noor the black former
minneapolis police officer who
accidentally shot and killed a white
woman
he was charged and convicted of third
degree murder and sentenced
to 12 years now if potter a white woman
is convicted of second degree
manslaughter she faces
a lighter sentence as short as four
years behind bars now the wright family
is hoping the charges will be
amended they want a stricter punishment
because
they call this act deliberate not an
accident
brian so kim what's next in the case
here
well this was just an initial court
appearance it was very quick a five
minute appearance over zoom just to
confirm some basic
information as well as identify who her
attorney is which is earl grey
they also set her next court appearance
for may 17th that court appearance is
supposed to be
in person brian thanks kim and terry as
kim was saying even though the former
officer is now
charged with manslaughter those charges
could be upgraded at some point couldn't
they
absolutely brian right now the
manslaughter is second-degree
manslaughter which means you know
culpable negligence the fact that
she created an unreasonable risk but if
the prosecution finds that there's
more there more evidence she really
could get more than that she could
obviously be charged with third degree
murder
and we saw that charge being reinstated
here in the george floyd derek chovin
trial
and that could happen here and that
means that she is acting without regard
to human life
so the maximum could go from 10 years to
25 years if in fact they find that and
obviously with
sentencing guidelines that could be
decreased but they could
if they think that they have enough
evidence and at any point
they could raise that charge all right
thanks terry
coming up on law and crime daily the
final witness is called in the derek
chauvin trial
as we await closing arguments plus
the decades-old investigation into a
missing college student
gets new leads the location where police
now believe
kristen smart was murdered that's next
[Music]
the father and son charged with the
murder and alleged cover-up of a
california college student in 1996
appeared in court for the first time cal
poly state university student kristin
smart
seemingly vanished 24 years ago after
leaving a party
her ex-classmate paul flores is now
accused of killing her
investigators recently searched his
phone and the homes of his family
members
they say new evidence links flores to
smart's murder
but her body has not yet been found and
now prosecutors are saying
flores killed smart while he was
attempting to rape her
the statute of limitations on a rape
charge from 1996 has already expired
considering the fact that kristen was an
adult over 18.
so we do not anticipate filing charges
for a specific rate
but the allegation that he was
committing or attempting to commit a
rate
while he uh when she killed her is the
basis for which
we are able to file first degree value
murder charges we do have evidence in
this case that leads us to conclude that
there
very well may be additional victims in
the southern california area
and i don't want to go into the nature
of of that
but he was known to frequent bars in the
san pedro area
and in los angeles county
so brian they say they're looking for
more evidence of other crimes paul
flores may have committed
but if they haven't found the body of
kristen smart how can they know he tried
to
rape her yeah brian ross
uh i have seen homicide cases without a
body
i have never seen a rape case without a
body i don't know how they're going to
be able to prove that i don't know who's
going to testify to that
and i think there's also a legal uh
hurdle as well
and the question becomes as you can kind
of heard that the prosecutor's saying
there
if you can't charge the person for rape
because of statutory limitations
how are you gonna use that as a
launching point to charge someone for a
higher crime i would expect a lot of
motions in this regard
and probably a a potential appellate
issue here as well
uh if they can't prove the fundamental
um building blocks to lead themselves up
to that charge
this is gonna be an interesting case uh
definitely to keep our eyes on it indeed
and terry this is a very cold case with
no body how do they make that case to a
jury
it's going to be very difficult brian if
you think about it when you have a body
that does help the investigation you can
understand that someone died
from a knife attack and you look for the
knife or whether there was a gunshot or
a blunt
trauma when you don't have a body you
don't have those types of clues so it
makes it much more difficult
so what the prosecution is going to need
to do is rely on the circumstantial
evidence
like perhaps there's some dna there or
perhaps the electronic information
that is available to the prosecution and
to the authorities so
they're going to also look at testimony
from other individuals witnesses
who might have seen her before she
disappeared it will be harder but it
is possible brian all right thanks terry
when we come back
back into the courtroom for the derek
chovan trial the defense's controversial
expert witness testimony
you don't want to miss this
back now to minneapolis where derrick
showdown's attorney called his own
forensic pathologist
to talk about george floyd's cause of
death on cross-examination
prosecutors went after the expert's
assessment that carbon monoxide from the
police vehicle
was a contributing factor
do you agree that you shouldn't come at
this in a way that's biased
you agree with that don't you absolutely
agree with that yes
you shouldn't cherry pick facts no you
shouldn't try to confuse the jury
correct you haven't seen
any data or test results
that showed mr floyd had a single injury
from carbon monoxide is that true
that is correct because it was never
sent to the borders
i asked you whether it was true sir yes
or no
uh do you agree with me that there was
no finding
of carbon monoxide poisoning
from mr from dr baker's autopsy review
i do and remember this expert says
george floyd died from cardiac
arrhythmia
not from derek shovin's knee a point the
defense made sure to get across on
what's called
the redirect based upon your review of
the
video in this case did you observe
mr chauvin's knee obstructing the
carotid artery of mr floyd
that knee did not obstruct either
carotid artery
and even if it had obstructed one the
carotid artery on the other side plus
the two
vertebral arteries would continue to
supply the brain with
enough blood for it to function
oh
did it appear to you that mr chauvin had
a tight firm grip around mr floyd's neck
no actually it looked very loose and the
hand was actually gripping the back of
the neck and the sort of spinal column
area
with a considerable gap in the front
so with closing arguments set for next
week the lawyers now have a long weekend
to get ready for their closing arguments
brian
what are the main points you would make
if you're doing the state's arguments
the main points i'd be looking at for
the state's argument would come from
chief aerodondo
dr tobin and then philonous floyd
because that's really where you're
getting a lot of the use of force
the medical information and as well as
the emotional impact when we think about
persuasion i know it's a bit of a
history lesson
aristotle actually talked just about
that the credibility
the logic and the empathy or the emotion
to help persuade people
and i think the prosecution had a lot
more of those three elements than the
defense did
and terry if you're on the defense side
what are the points they have to make
well i think the defense has a much more
difficult case hopefully they have been
preparing from
day one because to have a great closing
you need to make sure you're taking
notes their two main
issues are the use of force and the
cause of death
i think their strongest witness for the
use of force was
very broad although he was not very good
under cross-examination
but he came to the conclusion and the
jury is going to have to
determine whether or not they believe
him but he came to the conclusion
that chovin was justified and that he
was following
police procedures and so if that's the
case the jury is going to listen to that
and it's up to them
to believe whether or not he was
credible then you know they also
showed peter chang and he is the officer
who came to the scene and said that the
crowd was distracting and
to a certain extent i think that the
defense is going to have to focus on
that
we've already talked about the cause of
the death and
clearly fowler was the number one
witness
for the cause of death and i think we're
going to have to
look at whether or not the jury is going
to believe fowler and i think the
defense is going to
look and determine whether or not
fowler's testimony that
everything contributed and it wasn't the
knee on the neck the knee on the back it
was
all of these other issues like his heart
like
anxiety even carbon monoxide and so i
think that's what the defense is going
to have to focus upon
and brian very quickly what's the
mixture here of emotion and facts as you
make the closing arguments
so i think in closing arguments we're
going to be expecting a lot of the
arguments
that we've heard so far prosecution will
try to cover up all of those reasonable
doubt holes the defense are trying to
poke through
i don't know if it's going to really
work for the defense don't forget the
prosecution gets to go last in that
summation
all right brian and terry thank you so
much thank you all for joining us here
on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you